during
the public fight with one team i was
exhausted
because what happened is david boyce uh
bill clinton's lawyer weinstein's lawyer
uber passed gay marriage in the supreme
court gorzler gorby bush and i'm telling
you stuff yeah but others might not um
one of the good guys right big democrat
that's the worst he went to prime
minister who barack the former prime
minister of israel who should i hire to
stop rose mcgowan
and when i say this goes up to the
highest levels power it goes up to the
highest levels of power
black cube crawl
and pelicano dude and uh
they terrorized me
really intensively because they knew i
was writing a book the irony i never
intended on putting his name in my book
the book's not about him
uh it's using the story of what happened
to me to educate people further and and
get to see like the true lie
behind the image of hollywood
and and uh democrats power structure but
i was never going to put his name in my
book it's an ugly disgusting name
no my i i love words i love words i love
language
i don't know about you but when i was
writing a book sometimes it feels like i
had like every like the dictionary
sitting on my head and it was like ah
like because you know
it's a lot to write a book
and boring
not boring what you're writing but like
you have to sit still
and you're living inside your head oh no
people think writing is just when you're
doing that no like and i had never
written a book i'd never really done a
homework assignment
my mom was 15 she's like you never
finish anything and i was like oh god
what if that's true you know on set i
have a contract if i don't show up i'm
getting sued i have people following me
with walkie-talkies every minute of my
day is managed yeah so i didn't know if
i really did complete things or not but
i did shockingly but i did it while they
were flying drones around my windows
every day this three years before 2017
the weinstein news broke
i was
trailed almost driven off the road they
stole my headlights out of my car they
placed trackers in my car i thought i
was manifesting everything in my life
turns out my whole house was bugged um i
had like that swept like it would be
like i so i am
i was exhausted when the news broke and
my literary agent dupray miller um jan
miller they're bit they're big in fact
weinstein was doing a movie with trayvon
martin's family it was very sad actually
um with jay-z who also knows
um
and that got killed because the
weinstein you know that movie never came
out or got finished because of that but
the literary agency do pray miller
google them they're real nice so jan
miller she's like this dragon lady she
was like bragging to me about how close
she was with bill and hillary and and
her and david boyce are hanging out that
weekend and she's throwing a five
thousand dollar plate dinner for them in
dallas they're had their race in dallas
now what was happening
at that time any time i was making a
public appearance i knew people were
shadowing me my then boyfriend was like
i i i can't take it i'm being followed
my car is broken into like i can't take
it i'm being driven nuts and this is
three years ago before the news was
breaking but they knew i was writing a
book
um
he uh
so much to the story it's exhausting in
some ways but like four days after uh
knocking out weinstein at the new york
times
i iced roy price the head of amazon
studios by tweeting at jeff bezos you
know why not
one two three four at four points i was
make first you want a dirty oscar
casey affleck
like
an actor ben affleck's brother who
has been accused very credibly and i
think did settlements behind the scene
but i think that's what happened um
alleged violent predator
didn't care doesn't matter roy price the
head of this studio i had already known
from just you know he was under
investigation for a year before the
weinstein news broke
by his own company so he told me jeff
bezos doesn't know whose employee is
really
he was under investigation for a year
for sexually harassing
the head producer of the man in the high
castle
on amazon
who not that it matters but i think as a
married lesbian by sticking his like
tongue or something in her ear and like
whispering do you like it in the
stuff like that every day so she
actually filed a sexual harassment you
know thing with hr but they kept it
in-house but i read about it in the
trades but it didn't make wider news
right
so
one you want a dirty oscar jeff bezos
two at
roy price allison he followed me one day
on twitter it's like two years for the
expose i'm like whoa the head of amazon
studios has fired me i've been writing a
script about children of god the thing i
grew up on
and you know if you've ever written
anything how hard it is to get anybody
to read the damn thing yeah well
so
we started talking on twitter dming and
i'm like i wrote a script he's like i
would love to read it i send it to him
two days later i was like this is
amazing i'm like the head of a studio
within two days read
what
huh
then he does a huge deal with this roy
price head of amazon studios with woody
allen
saves his
i am at lunch with roy price one day at
the beverly hills hotel
and i just found out that weinstein was
going to go bankrupt and if he truly
gone bankrupt i would have just left it
there maybe i was thinking about them
um but he didn't because roy price
amazon studios came in to save them
turns out they bought my script to see
at weinstein's behest
to see if i had written anything about
him wow
so i had no intention of using it no
just sitting on it so it could never be
in circuit sorry i get emotional
sometimes because it's like i work so
hard
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else